lio tout le monde s'est choisi
aujourd'hui on se trouve pour une
seconde vidéo sur gauthé même voilà je
l'avais dit on devait tester toutes les
autres chefs donc c'est parti star n ai
jamais fait une intro aussi rapide c'est
puissant quand même hein elle cache bien
son jeu au succès de rouiller but pour
moi je veux qu'on aille faire la quête
là bas au milieu de la mer elle car mon
style et comme cette chèvre a été épique
par tous c'est petit armure bien plus
sexy notamment que ce micro ondes en
collant moulant la basilique est en
plein milieu de lomé où il regardé c'est
un poisson comment je peux t'aider dix
mois tout cas s'il te plaît une
indication claire en français ou en
anglais
enfin plus en français qu'en anglais
d'ailleurs j'ai une nouvelle quête glur
blog donc comment ça se passe comment ça
se passe plus tard après l'émoi votre
[ __ ] mais non plus puisqu'on prend la
quête de l'autre ah mais c'est vrai qu'à
notre ami a comme les ramener dans une
taverne
excusez moi je cherche à tavel n'ya pas
les gardes à qui parler qui nous indique
où la taverne comme dans tous les mémos
rpg bordel au hameau glace j'en ai
besoin
non mais l'armée y avait quelqu'un en
plus que j'ai complètement tué j'ai tout
gâché mais regardez il s'est pendu ce
pas là la taverne terme et je me fais
agresser par un meuble as tu un combat
épique entre une chèvre une bibliothèque
ou la chèvre à gagner moi je redis que
c'est ça à tavers mais bien sûr que
c'est ça là il est à la taverne alors
juste là ah ben voilà fallait que je
prenne avec ma langue
moi j'aimais dans mon sexe plus pratique
comme ça orange pourrait dire au moins
un petit merci voilà qu est la lhjmq est
ça doit être là dessous aller ont carte
blanche et ajuste la regarde et à la
messi ou c'est un enfer cette quête qui
serait bien c'est comme de trouver la
corne de démons j'ai vu ça me regarde et
qu un esprit démoniaque démons on aidera
de mulder a trouvé la corne démoniaque
je trouverais la corne d'un bol d'or par
là je peut la sentir tu peux sentir le
bon ben demie du matin pourquoi le
plaindre mais aussi à rien je pas un
caprice
eh bien ça doit être dur de l'éduquer
septième au moindre caprice tac
olalala petite route j'ai vu ça c'est ce
qui se passe merci à l'enterrement ça se
bat disparition voilà un moment il faut
toutefois suffi toutes ces conneries
bordel tristram cathédrale ah non y'a
rien à part regarder là dessous mon dieu
c'est un passage secret qui mène vers un
portail démoniaque n'a trouvé ça tout
seul vous rendez compte [ __ ] et la
pana travel yes faut que germaine la
corde démoniaque pour dumbledore il
compte sur moi au plus tard mais ça sent
rapport à diablo le niveau secret des
bâches mon gars s'accrochent qui vient
de l'espace équipe si vous laissez moi
[ __ ] de maintenant mais les mecs son
âme et attend mais sont trop fortes
maugard ont fui en ouvre donc il est
temps pauvre fou vient de remettre la
musique du jeu j'avais complètement
biais de la remettre à la dernière fois
un dock entorse fatigué par des vaches
comme des humains et qui tire des lasers
par la nasa c'est un peu normal oublier
deux choses n'ya pas genre là mais le
maître des vaches ou 1 tout comme sa
hauteur la ola au cheval et là où je
suis sûr que c'est là où vous allez voir
cours petite chérie sont puissants
regardez c'est lui les lieux ne brassent
déchets un [ __ ] elle me malmène les
mecs mais à nous mettre des vaches à
ahola huchon l'a défoncé been j'ai eu
dans mon inventaire je sais pas si c'est
ça qu'il nous fallait on va le tenter
c'est les démons est d'accord ça va ce
sera oui oui je veux m'en aller et non
j'ai toujours pas là la corne démoniaque
1 mais il est temps de changer de
chièvres actuellement je pense que c'est
là elle est assez traumatisés par les
vaches c'est bon on va lui laisser un
peu de repos l'inter est très mignon on
part sur du hunter on peut ni quelqu'un
parle des poissons oh [ __ ] on peut se
fondre les jo c'est génial à l'est tout
autant mais avec nous qu'ils voulaient
que je t'emmène mais je t'emmène mois
est franchement pour aller par exemple à
londres ben c'est beaucoup mieux de
prendre ça que pour l'eurostar je suis
désolé en plus ça veut pas du tout mal
au crâne
à deux pas du tout envie de vomir sac et
bien elle mais on peut s'accrocher
regarde alors là on a fait un truc de
pro je suis désolé je tout excité qu'est
ce qu'elle veut elle chausse bully
houser opté un poisson ça te va si je te
prends comme ça et que tu viens avec moi
là bas
et voilà ça a marché par exemple à des
petits d'oddo qui s'amusent entre eux tu
arrives bout de temps qu'il n'a pas et
tu t'en fous à l'irna gibier pour ce
soir femme ou lassé blue par ici d'un
coup l'ambiance change dont allez vous
messieurs dames arrêt de faire ça
vraiment arrête ça suffit oh mon dieu
elle se rebelle
on peut plus la prendre avec nous via
windows to the magic circle car il faut
prendre les dodos les amener mais
regardez tout ce qu'ils font arrêter
mais non tu n'es pas une limace tu n'es
pas un chien tu n'es pas s'appeler dodoz
venez à moi j'ai deux doses dans mon
truc si je l'aimé là ça fait quelque
chose
que dalle oya le beurre magique pour le
kate mon dieu à temps opportun ce ninja
ce ninja incroyable une dextérité folle
à bientôt
elle dort on a dérangé tout dans la
discrétion tout dans la discrétion
surtout dans la discrétion
il fait quoi cet homme là à gauche
[ __ ] llodra de fer l'ouest
j'abandonne overall les autres noms mais
pour moi c'est sami un boy excalibur
vient à nous il y avait un saloperies
l'epg deux quêtes à rendre ici aux plats
y ait de rien m'a dit vous avez mis
tellement de temps mais vas-y mais va
chier mon gars tu y vas votre noyer
j'ai ton bar ou et voilà est ce que tu
es content maintenant je veux ramener du
sucre en mai les gars vous abusez un peu
eh ben c'est le moment de changer de
chaîne et c'est le moment de prendre la
chèvre voleuse oui ou alors question
c'est ce qu'il aurait dû fait invisible
ah ok je pense c'est le coup de je suis
invisible et la embuscade là c'est idéal
pour infiltrer village de moutons je
pense mais j'arrive pas à trouver
l'accord démoniaque attendait la ja du
sucre parfait donc on a su qu'on n'a pas
la cote de démons je veux la [ __ ] de
corps de démons le regarder ou est ce
trop fait quoi qui aimeraient bien
l'aider mais je peux pas haut mais que
voici c'est un petit chemin ça dit donc
ils mènent [ __ ] encore importe moins
de poisson si génial qu'est ce qui se
passe ici donc les forges une petite
pierre géantes 7 n'aura pas la roue du
temps c'est quoi c'est ça ok je la prend
avec plaisir bien sûr je suis plus
heureux de faire avec ça bordel
vous allez me répondre pourquoi personne
ne répond jamais personne explique les
choses à moi je fais un caprice ou je
fais un cas précis fait comme le chef ok
on faisait via de la lawe là haut rang
il ya un passage justement ça veut dire
quelque chose
oh mais c'est là où le mec avec un prix
que j'ai tué l'araignée et le flash back
il m'a dit d'aller à l'ancienne montagne
des chèvres au il avait la corne y avait
l'accord du démon les l'accord du démon
au dôme bord va être tellement fiers de
nous j'en prends une deuxième juste pour
le plaisir
il ya un portail et ce portail noah nous
faut sauter là aux dates piège est là
mais arrêtez ça fait maintenant ok ça
c'est un peu un temple mais y'a quoi au
bout je ne sais pas où on a réussi au
presque c'est mon envie je tue qu'une
pauvre chien vinolas temps y'a combien
de kg au mètre carré quoi ça suffit à un
moment on arrive dans une pièce immense
mais qu'un dinosaure qui mange et se
passe n'importe quoi dans cet épisode
c'est incroyable alors est-ce qu'on peut
monter sur ce dinosaure ou pas du tout
peut le ranger un inventaire le gros de
la wii et là on va voir double bord il
va être tellement fière de nouveau chez
attire les foules dont l'amour nous
attend il est pressé non c'est pas ce
pur qui nous retiendra dumbledore je
suis là tiens
aux lettres sur pozzato portal et il m'a
ouvert un portail pour qu'ils deviennent
riches demeures on fait comment travel
nous emmène ou ois mondiaux nous sommes
c'est un piège dans cette blague de me
le borgne le bas me faire ça tu es mais
non aux locaux qui rigole alain farine
nous amener au milieu de rien je peux
m'en je peux tomber mais perdus dans
l'espace temps on a en plus en vente
hergé
j'ai plus rien et matt damon mort qu as
tu pu noter que la vidéo je devais avoir
7 ans pour qu'ils nous la haine ou l'âme
est bon et l'allégeance à dire fois de
cette deuxième vidéo sur quand même on a
pu voir toutes les chèvres qui était
possible de prendre j'espère que souza
peut dans ce cas n'hésitez pas aimé la
vidéo comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à
me dire dans les commentaires si vous
voulez une troisième vidéo dans laquelle
ont fini toutes les quêtes ne faisait
que j'ai pas réussi à faire et ben là je
jouerais autant de temps qu'il faudra
pour terminer tous à savoir regardez
vous êtes top sur tout le monde sauf au
toit d'un bol bourthes a pas de piste au
hockey et toi t'as juste un
non